-Tiffany,
you're a great comedian,
and part of your job is
to have strong opinions
about all different
kinds of things.
So with that in mind,
I want to play a game
of "Wheel of Opinions."
♪ -Wheel of opinions ♪
-Here's how this works.
I'm going to hit this button,
which will activate
the opinion-topic generator.
It will land on a random topic.
Whatever it is, you have to give
an opinion on it.
Ready for this?
-She ready.
-I just wanted to
hear you say that.
Here we go.
TikTok challenge.
TikTok challenges.
-Now, let me tell you, I'm here
for a good TikTok challenge.
I love to see people
take on dance routines,
pranking their parents,
fun things like that.
I love a good TikTok challenge.
Just not doing it myself.
But sometimes I do,
but I prefer not to.
-By yourself, it's a no-go,
it's just bad?
-Yeah, 'cause I, like, get
the dance routine down.
It takes me two hours
to learn the routine.
Then I get it down,
then I see myself doing it,
and I'm like, "Nah, I'm good."
So I only like to do
TikTok challenges
with my nieces or nephews,
something like that.
With younger people
'cause I feel like
I might be too old for it.
-Gotcha. Let's get to
another topic here.
Okay, cats versus dogs.
-Okay, here goes the thing.
I got two dogs and I got a cat.
The cat from the movie "Keanu"
that I was in.
She lives with me and I'm pretty
sure she thinks she's a dog.
Cats are bossy.
Cats don't no play no games.
Dogs love to play games and dogs
love to follow directions.
-Yeah.
-So cats win.
Dogs follow.
-Oh, wow.
-And that's why I love me.
-Wow, "that's why I love me."
Oh, my gosh, interesting.
So it's possible you're
a cat and a dog person?
-I'm both. I'm both.
-Wow, that's amazing.
-I'm both.
-Alright. Here we go.
Surprise albums.
Everyone's dropping
a surprise album.
-I mean, I got like three
surprise albums out there,
but I don't even know if anybody
know about the surprise.
I suggest y'all go to iTunes and
Apple and check out your girl.
You know,
I'm on Spotify and all that.
I got a song called
"Come and Get Your Baby Daddy."
Got another song called
"I Got a Man."
Got another song -- I got
a bunch of songs out, actually.
Check me out.
-Too many surprises.
Too many surprises.
I love it.
Alright, here we go.
Final topic.
Psychedelic tea.
I'm assuming like mushroom tea
or one of these things.
-Okay, let me tell you something
about mushroom tea, okay?
It is not my thing.
Okay, so I went to
Dave Chappelle's, right?
To do some comedy.
I got peer-pressured into
drinking the tea.
Now, I'm gonna tell you.
I don't do drugs.
It's not my thing.
But I said,
"Okay, I'm gonna drink this tea
since everybody else is."
And I drank it.
And Jon Hamm was there.
And as Jon Hamm is talking,
he started to look like
Phylicia Rashad.
And as I started looking around,
everybody started looking like
Phylicia Rashad.
The black people,
the white people.
Dave Chappelle looked like
Phylicia Rashad,
bald-headed with pointy ears.
I think I had to go to therapy.
I went to my therapist.
-[ Laughs ]
That's a weird trip.
-A Phylicia Rashad issue,
and I think it's because
I really want Phylicia Rashad
to be my mama.
-Yes, we all do.
-I'm gonna have to write a movie
and cast her in it to be my mom.
That's what I gathered from
that, and I will no longer.
-That is trippy.
Alright, you win.
You win the night.
You are the best.
Thank you for playing
"Wheel of Opinions."
My thanks again to
the great Tiffany Haddish.
Congrats again on the Emmy nom!
We miss you.
Hope to see you in person.
-Thank you.
-Bye, bud.